And no,
it can't stand
because it deisa in evidence,
hopes to defend their interests,
Galicians and galets,
in all,
of we get 1 agreement that cries to my life
the Galicians and the Galicians.
What did we get,
Mr. Rueda?
I have not achieved anything.
The dovenegade deal is 1 BoA news for Galicia,
but that is 1 bad news for the popular party.
That's why he's so angry or the only one she asks for,
huh?
What a notempo,
discount,
Ella stays.
If you are not able to sweat,
at least he doesn't paw Rodas.
Non persudique os interests 2 Galicians and 2 Galicians,
on solely and exclusively,
because it bothers him that this country is moving forward
fats you agreements.
Thank you